hello welcome to trigonometry this isn't
one of our interviews this is a thank
you video for everything that you've
done for all the support you've given us
both financial and moral it is so so
appreciated thank you so much we have
got really exciting plans coming up in
the very very near future one of those
is we now have a Clips channel where you
can come and see shorter clips of the
episodes so if you've got a short
attention span or ADHD like Francis you
can just go there and watch some short
clips so that's coming that's already
there you go and subscribe there now and
we will be putting out content very
shortly but the other thing as Francis
says we've had so much support from so
many people people emailing us people
giving us money people subscribing on
patreon and subscribe style and PayPal
it has made an absolutely huge
difference it means that we can keep the
show going and not only that we can keep
making it better so the plans that we've
got now is we're already saving money
towards getting better video equipment
to towards getting better bigger guests
to putting out more episodes than one a
week and so on so the more you support
us the more we will be giving back to
you another way if you fancy it what
we've got now is an opportunity for you
to get one of these mugs straight away
you don't have to subscribe you can just
pay a certain amount through a company
called teespring here on YouTube and get
one of these mugs there's also phone
cases there will be t-shirts and other
merchandise coming so thank you if you
already supported us thank you so much
if you've spread the word about the
channel thank you so much keep
supporting us and we promise we will
keep making more and better content for
you thank you very much guys and lastly
think of it like this and more money you
invest the more people where we can
reach an event inevitably piss off so
that sounds pretty good to me you know
it does actually that won't mean that's
why we started the channel but anyway
thank you so much and see you soon